warum gibt es fast nur materie und kaum
antimaterie im universum
der grund ist eine asymmetrie zwischen
beiden materie arten jetzt gibt es einen
ersten hinweis auf diese asymmetrie
zwischen materie und antimaterie wie
forscher auf diesen hinweis gestoßen
sind und mehr jetzt bei pixum science
fiction und uhr herzlich willkommen
worum geht es um anti mcafee ist genau
das gegenstück zur materie die uns immer
und überall umgibt ein anti atom
letztlich also aus denselben teilchen
eigentlich zusammen wie ein normales
auto nur eben an
das sieht zum beispiel so aus ein
wasserstoffatom besteht aus einem
positiv geladenen protonen und einem
negativ geladenen elektronen ein
antiwasserstoff atomen besteht aus zwei
teilchen so genannten anti teilchen
nämlich einem antiproton und einem
positiv das antiproton ist also das
gegenstück zur proton und somit nicht
positiv sondern negativ geladen und das
publikum nimmt den platz eines elektrons
1 und somit nicht negativ sondern
positiv geladen ein wasserstoffatom und
ein anti wasserstoff atom sind also
gleich aufgebaut mit dem einen
unterschied dass ihre teilchen eine
unterschiedliche ladung aufweise von
außen betrachten sind aber beide atome
elektrisch neutral und laut der
sogenannten cpi in variante genau gleich
aufgebaut diese theorie der direkten
raum spiegelung könnte aber nun veraltet
seien und damit wäre der grund für die
asymmetrie zwischen materie und
antimaterie gefunden denn forscher am
cern in genf wind mit dem large hadron
collider kurz lhc aber dem größten
teilchenbeschleuniger der welt auf
widersprüchliches gestoßen
sie analysierten den zerfall von
sogenannten lamba b0 ba regionen 6000
mal geschah das in den ersten drei
jahren des lhc betrieb die von der pp in
variant vorhergesagte symmetrie konnte
nicht bestätigt werden
sie besagt ja dass bis auf die lage im
raum alles gleich sein müsste alles
gespiegelt ist das ist aber nicht der
fall
lamba b0 baron und lampe 0 anti marion
unterschieden sich der winkel mit denen
die zerfallsprodukte aufeinander
schossen die unterschieden sich um 20%
den wissenschaftlern zufolge wäre das
der erste hinweis auf eine cd verletzung
bei mario hat man damit also tatsächlich
den aller ersten hinweis auf die
asymmetrie bei teilchen der antimaterie
gefunden
zitat auch wenn wir daher noch nicht von
einer entdeckung
brechen können handelt es sich hier um
ein sehr vielversprechendes
experimentelles in die wir müssen nun
auf die endgültige bestätigung oder
widerlegung warten die in ein paar
monaten abgeschlossene auswertung der
daten von der zweiten laufzeit des lhc
wird dies hoffentlich liefern berichtete
martin kusch am stück vom l hat sicher
wir können also gespannt bleiben jetzt
bleibt mir nur noch zu sagen druck mehr
hier
hier bezieht irgendwo erscheinen ein abo
aus auge und um das video zum ergebnis
dieser weiteren auswertungen nicht zu
verpassen könnte mir auch noch gerne
einen oft die glocke geben ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran